[موسيقى]
مبدئيا انا عايز قبل ما ابتدي التوب
بتاعتي اشكر كل الحاضرين لان بصراحه انا
ما كنتش متخيل الحضور هيبقى بالطاقه
الايجابيه دي كلكم بصراحه مديني طاقه
ايجابيه جامده قوي وبشكركم ان انتم عملتوا
مجهود انتوا تاروا تيجوا النهارده من
محافظات مختلفه وحابب اتكلم عن النهارده
ايفا ورد يعني اعرف على العالم بتاعك
ا حد منكم سال نفسه في يوم ايه اهميه ان
انت بتقدر تتعرف على الناس والاشياء
ببساطه الانسان بيستخدم الحواس المختلفه
علشان يتعرف على الناس والاشياء المختلفه
وبناء على التعرف ده بيبني قاعده بيانات
جوه المخ ويبتدي يتعامل مع الحاجه دي
بطريقه معينه بس مع الوقت الحاجات والناس
كترت قوي وكلها بقت شبه بعض فبد اناا نفكر
ان احنا نعتمد على التكنولوجيا عشان
التكنو التكنولوجي عشان نساعد الناس انها
تتعرف على الحاجات بسرعه ودقه اكبر على
سبيل المثال استخدمنا البطايق عشان نبتدي
نتعرف على الناس وللاسف الحرب العالميه
الثانيه بكل مساوئها كان ليها مميزات
كتيره قوي ان حصلت طفره كبيره قوي في
التقنيات بشكل عام وبداوا يستخدموا
الرادارات في التعرف على الطيارات ورادار
ببساطه هو جهاز بيطلع موجات تخبط في الجسم
ترتد له من خلال الموجات دي يقدر يتعرف
على سرعه وحركه الجسم ايه هي ده البار كود
متالي كتير قوي منكم بيشوفوا على اغلبيه
المنتجات الموجوده حاليا ومن خلال البار
كود بنقدر نتعرف على المنتجات
المختلفه انا زي ما احمد قال اسمي خالد
المحجوب والنهارده حابب احكي لكم قصتي مع
الصوره دي دي صوره ناس بتحاسب في السوبر
ماركت وزي ما انتم شايفين على فكره ده
سوبر ماركت حجمه متوسط في امريكا ساعات
الموضوع ده بيبقى صعب جدا جدا بس ما
تخافوش مش دي القصه اللي اجي احكي لكم
عنها اكيد يعني
ا انا كان حلمي ان انا وانا صغير خير
اللهم اجعله خير ان انا اكون مهندس
وبالفعل الحلم اتحقق واتخرجت من جامعه
القاهره قسم اتصالات وبدات اعمل الدكتوراه
بتاعتي في يونيفرستي مسيسيبي في امريكا
واثناء و اناا بعمل الدكتوراه حصلت لي
حاجه بسبب الصوره دي اللي منكم سمع عن
سوبر ماركت اسمه ول مارت هو سوبر ماركت
كبير بيعمل ارباح بالمليارات وهم
بيستخدموا البار كود في التعرف على
منتجاتهم المختلفه جم في نهايه 2005 بداوا
يفكروا ان هم يستخدموا تقنيه جديده
تساعدهم في ان هم يتعرفوا على الحاجه بدقه
وسرعه اكبر وبالفعل طلبوا من كل الموردين
بتوعهم ان هم يبتدوا يستخدموا التقنيه دي
اللي حصل انا نفسي ما كنتش متوقعه ان
الشركات كلها بدات تدفع فلوس للمراكز
البحثيه المختلفه انها تبتدي تدرس وتطور
التقنيه دي واتفتح عندنا في
ل دراسه التقنيه دي وانا كنت من اوائل
الناس المنضمه ليه فهو غير مجر الدكتوراه
بتاعتي اول سؤال سالته نفسي زي ما كلكم
بتسالوا هو التقنيه دي اسمها ايه التقنيه
دي اسمها ي اف دي هو سيبكم الكلمات الكتير
ارف ايدي اختصار
دي وهي تقنيه بتستخدم الموجات في التعرف
على الحاجات من على بعد لا سلكيا
الموضوع بتشتغل ببساطه زي فكره الرادار
عشان كده اكلمت عن الرادار انا عايز اشوف
الليزر بوينتر شغال ط الموجات بتطلع تخبط
في التاجز اللي ملزوقه على المنتجات دي
ترجع لليدر يقدر يتعرف على المنتجات
المختلفه طيب السؤال التاني وزي ما انتم
شايفين التجات دي صغيره وهي عباره عن
جزئين جزء عباره عن اريال بيستقبل الموجات
وشريحه ذكيه جواها وهي مش محتاجه بطاريه
تقدر تشتغل من غير بطاريه لانها بتاخد
الطاقه بتاعتها من الجهاز اللي بيقراها
بدات اسال نفسي هي ايه ممزات التقنيه دي
مقارنه بالبار كود اللي هو السيستم
المستخدم
حاليا واكتشفت الاتي اللي حابب اشارككم
فيه مقارنه بالباركود تقدر تقرا 1200 منتج
في الثانيه مقابل منتج واحد وده نابع من
طبيعه انها بتتقري لاسلكيا من على بعد فمش
محتاج تحط المنتج بتاعك زي البار كود قدام
الجهاز اللي بيقراها بيسموها لاين اوف
سايت ن لاين اوف سايت الترم الهندسي
بتاعها كمان زي ما ونتيجه الطبيعه دي يا
جماعه اقدر اتعرف على اماكن المنتجات
بتاعتي بدقه زي فكره الجي بي اس بس جوه
المباني بيسموها اندور
لوكيشن اللي اكتر من كده انها فيها اي
سهايا او تشيبا التشيب دي تقدر تكتب
المعلومات عليها وتمسح وتقرا المعلومات
وقت ما تحب كمان ممكن يكون فيها سنسور او
اجهزه استشعار تستشعر حاجات جات مختلفه زي
الحراره والضغط وهكذا تي دلوقتي كلنا بدات
توضح الرؤيه عندنا لمؤسسات كبيره قوي فكرت
تستخدم التقنيه دي انا كصاحب مكان هبقى
قاعد في مكاني شايف المنتجات اللي عرفت
عارف هي فين عارف ايه اللي تباع واللي لسه
موجود اللي صلاحيته قربت تنتهي رؤيه كامله
للمكان وانا قاعد في مكاني مش محتاج اقوم
ادور على
المنتجات كمان احنا كمستهلكين ودي الحته
المهمه انا بالنسبه لي ما يهمنيش صاحب
المكان انا انا مش صاحب المكان بس يهمني
انا كمستهلك هقدر اعرف معلومات اكتر بكتير
قوي عن المنتج بتاعي لانه ببساطه من ساعه
ما المنتج خرج من المصنع لحد ما وصل لايدي
يقدروا يكتبوا عليه معلومات ويمسحها زي ما
هم عايزين زي ما قلت كمان نفترض ان هو
بيقيس الحراره فتقدر تعرف درجات الحراره
المختلفه اللي ععد بيها المنتج لحد ما وصل
لايدك فلو هو دوا على سبيل المثال تبقى
عارف ان هو صالح للاستهلاك القدمي ولا لا
الاكتر من كده ان مادش في وداعا خلاص ل
توابير السوبر ماركت حاسب على 1200 منتج
في الثانيه بدل ما بحاسب على منتج
واحد طيب بعد ما خلاص عرفنا التقنيه
وفهمنا بتشتغل ازاي ببساطه وبدات اسال
نفسي احنا ازاي ممكن نطورها ونجحنا احنا
كفريق عمل ان احنا نحط اطار عام لتصميم
التاجز دي بحيث انها تتقري من على مسافه
ابعد فلما تتقري من على احنا وصلنا حد 18
متر فلما تتقري من على مسافه ابعد بنحس
كفاءه التقنيه ككل الا اهم من كده كانت
فكرتي الشخصيه ان انا
ا غيرت شكل التاجات الهندسي ونجحت ان انا
استخدم اللوجو بتاع الجامعه بتاعتنا او
العلامه التجاريه فزي ما بنقول بالمصري
انتم عارفين المصريين دايما بيحبوا يعملوا
يضربوا عصفورين بحجر واحد دلوقتي تقدر
تعمل ماركتنج او تعمل اعلان لشركتك عن
طريق العلامه التجاريه او اللوجو بتاعك
وفي نفس الوقت تقدر تتابع منتجاتك بمنتهى
الدقه والسرعه عرضت الفكره على اداره
الجامعه وفجئه ان هم رحبوا بها جدا لدرجه
انب رئيس الجامعه طلب مننا ان احنا نعمل
بايلوت بروجكت يعني مشروع صغير جوه
الجامعه يشوف المميزات التقنيه ايه وبدانا
فعلا نفكر نستخدم التقنيه في المكتبه بتاع
الجامعه بحيث انا كان عندي مشكله معرفش
اللي منكم عنده اونلاين سيستم في الجامعه
بتاعته كنت الاقي الكتاب اونلاين موجود بس
اروح المكتبه مس بليس محطوط في مكان تاني
مش عارف اوصله فانا باستخدام التقنيه دي
اعرف احدد فين اماكن الكتب وبالتالي
الطلبه والناس اللي شغاله في الجامعه
حياتهم تبقى اسهل بكتير كمان اللي فقد
حاسه ان واس على سبيل المثال المكفوفين
دلوقتي مادش محتاج اي حد مساعده من اي بني
ادم يقدر باستخدام التقنيه دي يعرف اماكن
الكتب فين
لوحده على فكره مكتبه اسكندريه هنا في مصر
مطبقين في احنا مطبقين فيها السيستم
ده كمان متالي دي بقى حاجه هتلمس كل واحد
فينا الباركن بتاع الجامعه عشان العربيات
بيبقى عليها البادج بتاع الجامعه عشان تخش
ترف تكن في الجامعه بيبقى عليها اللوجو
بتاع الجامعه تقدر من خلال التقنيه دي
تعرف الاماكن الفض فين في البارك تبعتلك
على تطبيق على التليفون قبل ما تروح تقف
في الزحمه وانت مش عارف المكان
فين انا حاليا شغال مدير في شركه تمبل
نافيجيشن مدير فريق بنعمل على تطوير
وتصميم الحلول باستخدام الار اف اي دي وفي
نفس الوقت انا من الام اي تي شغال ريسيرش
في الام اي تي مع اوتو اي دي لاب هوو واحد
من اكبر او اللاب الرائده
في تصميم وتطوير التقنيات التعرف بشكل عام
عشان كده اسمه اوتو اي
ديلا ومن خلال شغلي انا داما مقتنع ان
المهندس مش مجرد ان هو بيتعلم نظريه
الهندسه هي تطبيق العلم فلازم يكون ايده
كمان في الصناعه فمن خلال شغل سواء في
الصناعه او في البحث العلمي فقعدت افكر في
التطبيقات المختلفه اللي التقنيه دي ممكن
نستخدمها فيها واكتر من كده شكل الحياه في
المستقبل هيبقى عامل ازاي احب اقدم لكم
التلاجه الذكيه وهي
وهي وهي
ببساطه وهي ببساطه ثلاجه فيها جهاز بيقرا
الار اف اي دي فتقدر تعرف المنتجات اللي
جواها ايه خلاص وتقول لك ايه اللي قرب
صلاحيته ينتهي وبالنسبه لنا استهلكت كم
سعر حراري فالل بيعمل ريجيم نقدر نبعت لك
جرز ان انت استهلكت اكتر من سؤلات حاريه
معينه وبالنسبه لنا احنا هنا في مصر ممكن
يبقى الكهرب ب الثلاجه على خفيف
يعني
طيب احب اطمن كل ام وكل زوجه ان من
النهارده ان النهارده ماعدناش هنقدر نمسى
اي حاجه لان ببساطه الثلاجه لو اوصلت
بالانترنت لو سمحت ما حدش يوصلها
بالانترنت بس لو اتصلت بالانترنت هتبعت
على التليفون بتاعك تقول لك ان انت الحاجه
الفلانيه ناقصه ف ماعدش لك حجه تقول
فاكرين الورقه بتاع زمان بتتلزق على باب
التلاجه مادش ليها لازمه
خلاص الاكتر من كده ان اقدر اساعد زي ما
قلت اللي فقد حسه من الحواس انه يتعرف على
الحاجه واحنا كمستهلكين تقدر تعرف فييه
كمم سور حراي في المنتج معلومات اكتر بتير
ق عن
المنتجات التطبيق الثاني هو تطبيق برض دمه
خفيف جدا وماعرفش اللي منكم دخل يروح
يشتري لبس برضو غرفه تغيير الملابس الذكيه
طبعا كل حاجه دلوقتي التليفون بقى كل حاجه
في حياتك بقى فيها نوع من انواع
الذكاء الموضوع ببساطه ان انت او على فكره
الحاجات دي احتمال كبير قوي انا شفتها في
شو وبنعمل على تطويره كان بستخدموا
الريدرز بتاعتنا بس الفكره ان هي هتبقى في
المستقبل قريب جدا هتشوفوا الحاجات دي
غرفه تغيير الملابس او ما هتخش كل
المنتجات هتتقل ويرسلي لان فيها الار اف
اي دي فالمرايه اللي قدامك تتحول لتش
سكرين توريك شكل الهدوم هيبقى عامل ازاي
وللبنات اللي بيحب ايه اللي ينيق مع ايه
وايه اللي عليه ديسكونت النهارده وفي موقف
كان بيحصلنا انا شخصيا بعد ما خلاص جبت
حاجات جاي قسها لقيت محتاج نفسك محتاج يا
اما مقاس اكبر يا اما لون مختلف كنتوا
تعملوا ايه حل من الحلين يا تلبس هدومك
كلها وتخرج تجيب اللي انت عايزه يا اما لو
معاك حد بره بتزعق وكل المحل يعرف انت
مقاسك او اللون اللي انت بتدور عليه ايه
واحتمال تلاقي واحد ريب جايبه لك
اصلا دلوقتي مش محتاج تعمل كده لان ببساطه
هتش السكرين اللي قدامك المعلومه هتوصل
للناس تشتغل في المحل بره ويجيبوا ك
الحاجه اللي انت عايزها يا جماعه الهدف من
التقنيات دي ان احنا نتعرف على الحاجه
بدقه وسرعه
اكبر
طيب حابب اخدكم لشكل الحياه اللي منكم سمع
نتيجه انتشار الار اف اي دي ده وقال لك
خلاص المنتجات كلها يبقى عليها ار اف اي
دي برض الاوتو اي دي لاب ظهر ترم اسمه برض
في الا اي تي اسمه الانترنت اوف تينز تالي
هتلاقي كتير منكم سمعوا عنه وهو مع انترنت
الاشياء بمعنى ان كل حاجه حواليك تبقى
متوصله بالانترنت او انا شايف كلكم سمارت
فونز كل ده متوصل بالانترنت طيب لما حاجه
زي كده تحصل وتتعمق ايه اللي هيحصل ح با
اخدكم لشكل الحياه في المستقبل منها نقدر
نتكلم عن المدن نتكلم عن الطاقه نتكلم عن
حاجات كتير قوي باستخدام التقنيات دي شكل
الحياه في المستقبل هيبقى عامل ازاي كل
حاجه حواليك هيبقى فيها نوع من انواع
الذكاء الاصطناعي بمعنى من اول البيت اللي
بيعرف ان انت خرجت منه فيوفر الكهرباء
ويقفل الانوار لحد الثلاجه اللي بتقول لك
انت اكلت ايه لحد العربيات لو تسمعوا
حاليا العربيات اللي هتبتدي تقول لك الطرق
الاسرع فين استهلاك البنزين الاقل هيبقى
عامل ازاي وممكن العربيه تسوق نفسها
لاشارات المرور اللي هتوفر على حياتنا
حاجات كتير قوي يعني المرور هنا يعني ازمه
كبيره قوي الاشارات المرور يبقى فيها نوع
من انواع الذكاء تتغير وقت ما يكون الوقت
مناسب كل الابحاث اللي احنا بنعملها في
الام اي تي او في الشركه لان الصناعه برض
مهمه لان مش دايما الفكره لازم تطبيق
الفكره كمان بقى مهمه قوي ومنن خلال على
فكره شغلي في الصناعه عرفت ان في معوقات
كتيره قوي في المستقبل ممكن نواجهها وده
بيعلمك ازاي تعرف تعدي المعوقات دي كل
اللي احنا بنحاول نعمله ان احنا نخلي حياه
الانسان اسهل واذكى واسرع بحيث ان كل حاجه
حواليك تساعدك على اتخاذ القرار السليم
سواء على مستوى الافراد او مستوى المؤسسات
او حتى مستوى الحكومات وديتها دي حاجه
مهمه قوي راجع هرجع بكم تاني للحاضر ونتم
كلم عن دول بدات تستخدم التقنيه دي في
قطاع الصحه وخصوصا المستشفيات المستشفى
ممكن تقسمها لثلاث حاجات رئيسيه البشر
اللي هي الناس اللي في المستشفى سواء
الدكاتره او الممرضين او المرضى والاجهزه
اللي هي اجهزه القياس المختلفه والادوات
اليوميه اللي بتبقى موجوده بشكل يومي زي
الحقن والملايات
وهكذا وهاخدك في سيناريو ح بيحصل حاليا ما
بتكلمش عن المستوى بتكلم في الحاضر اول ما
المريض بيخش المستشفى بيعرف ان خالد مثلا
على سبيل المثال جه نتيجه الار اف اي تي
اللي معايا فيظهر سجل علاجي كامل للمريض
واللي مك دكتور في القاعه هيقدر يعرف
اهميه قد ايه ان انت تبقى عارف تاريخ
العلاج للمريض بيحسن كفاءه العلاج بشكل
رهيب الاكتر من كده اداره المستشفى تقدر
تعرف مين اللي موجود عندها في المستشفى
الاستاف اللي موجود النهارده مين وتقدر
وقت الازمات او وقت الطوارئ تتعامل معاهم
بشكل اكثر كفاءه نفس الكلام للاجهزه همنع
سرقه الاجهزه الغاليه على سبيل المثال
الاهم من كده حياه البشر ممن يا جماعه
الاهم من كده في دول جنوب شرق اسيا بداوا
يستخدموا التقنيه دي في التعرف على
الادوات اللي بتيجي من اقسام الامراض
المعديه ويقدر يتعامل معاها بشكل المظبوط
يعني انا عايز اوريكم اهميه التعرف قد ايه
على الحاجه لما اعرف ان ده جاي من قسم
امراض المعديه هتعامل معاها بالطريقه اللي
هي المفروض يتعامل معاه بيها وبالتالي ما
تخشش انت المستشفى عندك مرض بسيط تخرج
عندك كارثه لقدر الله
انا اتكلمت عن المستشفى نفس الفكره زي ما
كان احمد بيقول نقدر ناخد ناخد كل ناخد
نفس الفكره اقدر اعمم الفكره دي على اي
مصلحه حكوميه يعني مش لما رخصتك تتسحب
يبقى انتهى الامرط تطلع بد
ف انا وانا صغير كان حلمي ان انا اكون
مهندس والحلم الحمد لله اتحقق والنهارده
انا جاي مخصوص عشان اشارككم في حلم مش تحق
يرنا
كلنا التقنيات دي يا جماعه انا نفسي اشوف
بلدي بتستخدم التقنيات دي في تسهيل حياه
المواطن وان شاء الله ما نبقاش بس
مستخدمين لا كمان نبقى مطورين ومبدعين في
التقنيات دي لان ببساطه التقنيات دي
تقنيات لسه جديده ومجال البحث والتطوير
مفتوح فيها وكبير ومش بس مقتصر على
المتخصصين كل واحد مننا في مجاله يقدر
يستخدم التقنيات دي من اول مساعده
المكفوفين زي ما انا قلت كبار السن لحد
تعليم الاطفال وانا هقف هنا واقفه لان انا
لازم ابتدي اعلم ابني من دلوقتي ان
المستقبل هيبقى عامل ازاي لان هو مبدع
ومطور
المستقبل ايه رايكم ان احنا من السنه
الجايه ان شاء الله ان تد اكس كايرو يبقى
بيستخدم الار اف اي دي في الستريشن بتاعته
ونقف خمس دقاق بدل ا كان الوقت اللي احنا
افناه
[تصفيق]
النهارده وانا سعدهم على
كده
في النهايه انا حابب اقول ان احنا عمرنا
ما هنوصل للحريه اللي احنا بنحلم بيها بجد
الا من خلال تطوير التعليم والبحث العلمي
شكرا يا
[تصفيق]
جماعه